joining me tonight our professor andrew
hayward who is a member of sage and the
new and emerging respiratory virus
threats advisory group or nerve tag we
have mark jeep professor of vaccine
epidemiology and a member of spy m the
sage subcommittee on modelling and dr
angelique kozier chair of the south
african medical association and the
first physician to raise the alarm about
the omicron variant just a few weeks ago
very good to see you all thank you very
much indeed for joining us this evening
on sky news tonight we've got a lot of
questions to get through and uh i'd like
to start uh with this one the first
we've
picked out and uh it's almost as if i'd
written it myself i haven't but i'm in
this situation i've had two astrazeneca
vaccinations and a fisa booster and this
applies to many millions of people i
suspect in the united kingdom
the question is therefore am i protected
experts are actually saying three pfizer
jobs are needed so professor jeep
perhaps uh you can address this first of
all two astrozenica vaccinations
initially then a fisa booster
well the uk health security agency has
actually looked at that combination when
it looked at all the people who have had
omicron already and it found that anyone
with an mrna booster so fisa and
moderner has good protection against
omicron regardless of whether the first
two doses were astrazeneca and pfizer i
mean the other piece of evidence we have
is from clinical trials of the booster
and those looked at lots of different
combinations and those found that a
pfizer booster on top of a vaccine
whether that's astrazeneca or pfizer
does substantially increase the
antibodies that that person has to a
high level so i'd say absolutely the
pfizer booster will give a
substantial boost to protection
regardless of whether the first two
doses were astrazeneca or
reassuring on that flowing on from that
now put this to professor hayward first
of all what is the percentage chance of
becoming infected with omicron if you
have had three doses of the fisa vaccine
so you've you've had uh the two plus the
booster do we know if we got the data on
what the percentage chance now becoming
in fact it is
well i think that's that's a pretty hard
question to answer because it depends on
how much omicron there is and whether
you get exposed to it but what you what
you can say is that if you've had the
booster dose um whether or not you had
astrazeneca as your first dose
you you will get a good level of
protection against infection somewhere
between about 70 and 80 percent there's
still some uncertainty it may be a
little bit higher maybe a little bit
lower
but importantly your protection against
severe disease will be
even higher than that i think that
so those sound like good levels of
protection but i think the worrying
thing is if we get
so many uh huge numbers of infections uh
then uh even though people are quite
well protected that will still lead to
breakthrough infections and breakthrough
hospitalizations
i want to put that issue of breakthrough
infections to you dr kurtzia because of
course some you've been dealing with
omicron for longer than us and of course
identified it first of all um in south
africa emerging from botswana of course
um what are you seeing with a much lower
level of vaccination in south africa
what are you seeing in terms of
infection breakthrough
good evening um yes we are seeing
uh again on a primary health care level
in the community
it's nearly 50 50 um patients
unvaccinated versus people who had
previously been um
infected with covert
or who had in covet
the the um
two pfizers
um who had fire
[Music]
or um johnson and johnson never had
kowitt before
uh all of that we categorized in one
category as um versus unvaccinated so
unvaccinated means you never have been
recorded that you had previously been
before uh um encountered any of the
covet
diseases
as in as as by definition so it's 50 50
what you see in the community however
again
in the community
even if you get breakthrough infections
symptoms are still mild which no one um
you know it seems to me like a word that
i should not use anymore so let's say
they are
moderate and
we also see that this intensity of the
symptoms
are less
severe with the patients who's been
vaccinated so
for now in our hospitals
in our icus
the majority between 88 and 90
are unvaccinated people unfortunately we
don't have the data to say to you that
those ones are in icu or delta or
omnicron
and it's difficult on the clinical
picture so we just say that they are
delta they are covered 19 cases
um and that's it yeah yeah absolutely
yeah
clearly clearly army coroner delta the
vaccines are still
very effective against hospitalization
and on that uh i want to put this first
of all to you professor hayward our
third question what number of cases per
day or hospitalization figures would you
consider as the trigger point for full
country lockdown of course we've seen
today the record number of cases in 78
000
but we are told that um really we've got
to keep an eye on the on the
hospitalization and indeed death numbers
but they are lagging the cases
yeah of course i i don't have a clear
answer on that it's it's largely a
political decision i think the the key
concept is is this one of the nhs
becoming overwhelmed so what does that
mean i think it it really is
you know so for example if we get so
many cases that we're having to start to
turn away people who need emergency care
or our intensive care units are becoming
full and we're not able to give people
the care that they need
then i think nobody will want to see
that and and
and and it's that sort of situation that
will lead to further restrictions
yeah and professor jeet i mean this is a
kind of catch-22 though isn't it because
some the health service is already
dealing with the backlog from from
previous lockdowns and and cancellations
of so-called non-urgent care not known
to many people suffering from those
conditions and
if we do it again then the backlog just
gets heavier
yeah i think i agree with um well
professor hayward that in the end the
decision about lockdown that's a
question for the government and they'll
have to take many things into
consideration besides the health
situation but i think absolutely the key
indicator is the number of hospital
admissions we are in a better place i
think than we were one and a half years
ago when we didn't have the vaccine
because most people have been vaccinated
and many people now have the boosters
even though they're going to be many
cases hopefully the proportion of them
who get hospitalized or die will be
smaller so the the cases the link
between cases and severe disease will be
um weakened but it's not completely
eliminated so if we get enough cases
there will still be lots and lots of
hospitalizations and we'll get into that
very tricky situation that um professor
hayward was talking about so i think
absolutely we need to keep our eye on
the hospitalizations and unfortunately
they will rise as cases rise okay they
will rise at the moment fairly i mean
relatively low uh in terms of what's
gone on in the past but as we heard
today as we all know it's that lags the
number of cases well now i've got uh
this this question which is on
everyone's lips i suppose globally and
dr kurtzia i know you've you've talked
about it you just talked a little bit
about it already to me but the question
is directly and simply is it true that
the omicron variant is milder
than delta and i should say we've heard
from england's chief medical officer
professor chris whitty this evening
saying that um he thinks that uh it is
not that it's it's a bit of a myth tell
me your experience and your view
yeah that is uh
it seems to be the trick question so
again
in the communities
that the clinical picture that we are
seeing is that of mild disease however
people are admitted in hospital got
severe disease
so my best answer here would be to
to go out and to ask your gps your
family practitioners what are they
seeing how do they experience the
symptoms of these patients and how many
patients do they admit and how many
patients
are severely ill
from what they are seeing in the
community
i think
your own experience will help
we can we can tell you what we see in
south africa but maybe you will have a
different experience
also remember
that um we have seen
quite a
year now we still out of our
delta wife you still in the delta wave
so i think the difficulty again for you
would be to
distinguish um clinically at primary
healthcare level
or between delta and omnichrome although
delta omnicron is quite easy if you know
the symptoms and
also remember the other thing is that we
are you are also now asking or hopefully
your people to go and get tested if they
have symptoms so obviously your
positivity must raise and your numbers
must raise because you are testing more
people and and i think that's a very
important part in any
uh
wave is to get your people to test
except that you will have a high
infectivity rate
and except that we are working here with
a fast bleeding virus we have never said
that it's not not transmissible we have
always said it is very transmissible
it's on par with delta
and it would
most probably be more transmissible than
delta but time will only turn us
but don't be astonished if your if your
numbers go up if your people are testing
because that's what you want you want
them to taste but i mean you have to you
have said dr gutsy in the past that um
you detect a degree of hysteria in the
united kingdom even an overreaction do
you not think that the measures are
simply prudent and uh that they will if
they are an overreaction be decalibrated
when the hard data comes in
well let's see what when the heart data
comes in um you know maybe we are just
more luckier because we are four weeks
ahead of you
and four weeks in in a clinical disease
is quite quite a long time
and um but i do appreci
you know um agree with what prof heywood
and prof mark said um earlier and you
know
the question
the hard questions is again how would
how would the virus play out in
in uk
versus how it played out in south africa
and south africa um you know it doesn't
matter how many times i look at it in a
different light
at community level it's still marked i
can't get away from it i can't say it's
a severe disease at community level or
however if you are admitted it is a
severe disease for those um in hospital
okay so
unfortunately uh keep watching and
waiting all that uh another specific
question and uh this is what to do with
with
the large amount of huge amount of
testing that's going on at the moment
and uh a question from a parent uh
saying my daughter had a positive pcr
test today how do i know what variant
she has actually caught and do all her
close contacts still need to isolate
regardless of their negative test
results so presumably her daughter
tested positive on pcr and her close
contacts have been informed
tested i'm guessing here on lateral flow
but they've got negative test results um
what what do they need to do professor g
do we know
i'd say to the first question um whether
what variant she caught um i it
it really depends on the test she was
given not all areas actually testing for
the particular variant she has but in a
sense of what to do there first of all
i'd like i'd like to emphasize i'm not
giving clinical advice because i'm not a
medical doctor but i would say
regardless of what variant the daughter
has we should follow the government
guidelines because all variants of
kovitt are potentially dangerous so
um well if the uh my understanding is if
the contacts are vaccinated then they
don't need to self-isolate but i would
still recommend that they keep um
testing with a lateral flow regularly
unless until they're very very sure that
they're negative
and that indeed is the uh is the
government guidelines to test daily but
uh no need if you're if you're
vaccinated to isolate at this point um
question another question here professor
hayward uh let's go to you initially
what advice would you give people who
were previously told to shield bearing
in mind the large number of new
infections so people who've been
shielding presumably for for quite a
long time what advice would you give to
them now with this huge number of cases
building
well i think people who were advised to
shield would have either been advised to
do so um previously because of their age
or because of having an illness that
increases their risk of getting severe
disease if infected they will also be
the people who've been prioritized for
booster doses of the vaccine so they
should have had their booster dose um by
now now that reduces your risk
of infection and severe disease by a by
a great deal
but on the other hand the fact that
we're moving into this position where
we've got
you know extraordinarily high
unprecedentedly high levels of infection
counteracts that so if it was me i would
still be being very careful over this
period of intense transmission to reduce
my contacts to those that are really
important
thank you very much for that um here's
another question on vaccinations so many
people um asking about uh boosters dr
kurtzia this would be interesting to get
the south african experience because
it's a question about um
boosters
vaccines versus natural infection the
question is do i need to get a booster
if i have recently had a covert
infection would i not then have natural
immunity for a time period and we were
just discussing there weren't we um how
the how the delta wave affected south
africa and uh how perhaps that's built
up quite a large degree of immunity
through that route is there any evidence
that uh natural infection is is better
in terms of immunity than vaccines and
boosters
um yeah there's this very nice starter
out there so the best that you can do
for yourself
is to um if you had natural immunity is
to get the booster that heterologous
type of immunity is the best immunity
that you can get
um
so the fact that you had it before we
know that even your natural immunity is
going to weigh down
um so and again if you can
you you know use your um you've got
astrazeneca and you've got pfizer and it
seems to me in your country
and and any of those especially the um
mrna boosters
these nice studies on it to get to say
yes you have to go and get it the the
immunity that you get from the booster
as well as your own immunity is really
really superb um there's no doubt about
it
okay i think this might be the last
question we can squeeze in which again
relates to that and it is this could
this rapidly spreading variant actually
end the pandemic if it's spreading as
fast as it's expected to can both a
vaccinated and unvaccinated develop an
immunity to it by catching it so that
would be a bumpy ride but could there be
a silver lining at the end of it uh
professor jeets
well i think what we hope is that we can
well at least bring this epidemic nut
down not by lots of people catching it
because if that happens then the
well the toll in terms of
hospitalizations and deaths will not be
good but we can try to reach that
position by giving as many people as
possible the vaccine and then the
booster so that they are actually
protected without having to have the
disease itself unfortunately some people
a lot of people already getting the
disease and eventually that will bring
some immunity to the population as well
but we're hoping that most of this
immunity comes through vaccination and
not from through natural infection which
will cause a lot of
bad disease okay professor hayward and
the first part of the question is could
this rapidly spreading variant actually
end the pandemic your thoughts
well i i i think the idea of it
if you mean by end the pandemic get
get rid of covid it's not going to do
that i think covet is going to spread
for a number of years but it will
it it will become
less severe over time i think um what we
tend to see in pandemics is we may get a
you know a couple of big waves a big
winter waves of infection and then it
starts to settle down as we as as we get
increasing levels of immunity both
through vaccination and natural
infection
so i think just because we're having to
take all these measures right now
doesn't mean that we're necessarily
going to have to do that every time a
new variant comes along
um so i i think the longer term picture
is much better than the shorter term one
do you share dr cartier do you share
those views
i i do share those views with prof
edward and the time is going to tell us
you know time time time is going to give
us a lot of answers but i i agree with
profe wood
well listen we've had as many answers as
we can get given the data we know so far
from you uh my steam panel thank you
very much indeed dr kurtzia professor
hayward professor jeep thank you all
very much indeed